so we were hearing there uh from the
chancellor amongst other things that he
was comfortable with the level of tax
that he was paying on his national
insurance do you think he should be
no i don't because i don't think that
the tax burden at the moment is falling
fairly i don't think it is right that
the national insurance increase
hits people in work and hits businesses
employing new people and yet if you get
your income from stocks and shares and
dividends or a portfolio of buy-to-let
properties you're not paying a penny
more in tax i don't think that strikes
the right balance especially at a time
when people are facing a cost of living
crisis this winter with petrol prices
gas and electricity bills the weekly
food shop all going up and the
government's response is taking more
money from people in taxes but he also
went on to say that taxes are starting
to be cut use referring to universal
credit and the amount of money that is
going to be added to try and offset the
six billion pounds that the government
is saving from reducing the 20 you know
all of this i'm just explaining it
obviously for our viewers because of
them taking away the 20 pounds a week
for some families um and he said you
know what people are just going to be
better off
that's just not true and it's not what
the institute fiscal studies
agreed with what they said
well
six billion pounds is being taken off
universal credit and the government put
less than half of that back in yesterday
um six million families lose out from
the 20 pounds a week
only 1.9 million families benefit from
the changes announced yesterday so it is
clear that some of those people on the
most
modest and low incomes are losing out
significantly by the chancellor's
announcements yesterday but also this
national insurance rise which comes in
next year costing more than 10 billion
pounds on families and businesses
actually that's the wrong tax at the
wrong time when people are facing all of
these additional costs now worries about
interest rates going up as well and not
asking those with the broadest shoulders
to pay a penny more i just don't think
that is the right balance i also think
more could have been done in the budget
yesterday around the cost of living
gas and electricity um bills five
percent of those the money goes directly
uh to the treasury in a in tax
we could cut that tax from five percent
to zero percent for six months to help
people get through these winter months
and that could be paid for by the fact
that vat receipts over the last few
months have been four billion pounds
more than forecast that's how labour
would help people with the cost of
living crisis right now and the
chancellor seems to be living in tens of
billions of pounds
a billion pounds for six months but vat
recedes over the last six months because
prices have been so high have come in
four billion pounds more than forecast
so labour would have made different
choices in the budget yesterday
different choices to ease the cost of
living crisis different choices on taxes
but also different choices to get the
economy growing because by the end of
this forecast period the office of
budget responsibility say that the
economy is just going to grow by 1.3 a
year
and that is much lower than what we've
experienced in the last 10 years and
much much lower than in the 10 years
before that and the truth is it's really
hard to lift living standards and
improve public services if the economy
is not growing properly so you need a
proper plan for growth that's why
investing in the zero carbon economy of
the future our plans to buy make and
sell more in britain so more good
quality jobs are created on these shores
are all essential for lifting living
standards and sustainably increasing and
improving public services tax rates are
at the highest rate uh since the 1950s
you know he's been described the
chancellor president chancellor has been
described as more brown than thatcher
well i i don't think that a budget from
gordon brown and certainly a budget from
me would have ignored the cost of living
crisis that's i think the real
difference between labor and
conservative right now and the issue
about taxes yes taxes are at their
highest level for more than 70 years
and yet public services are not the best
we've seen them for 70 years and that
burden of tax isn't falling fairly
nothing more to tax the online giants
who have made huge profits this last
year whilst high street businesses and
small businesses struggle nothing to ask
those with the broader shoulders to
contribute more just putting the burden
on working people through national
insurance and the businesses that employ
them you said yesterday you know
carrying on with that theme that
conservatives are now the party of high
taxation quoting you are labour going to
become the party of low taxation
the issue is around who is taxed and
under this government the burden falls
time and time again on the same people
working people on average incomes and
that's true whether it's the national
insurance contribution the freeze and
the personal allowance which means that
income taxes going up or indeed hidden
in the budget yesterday 6.9 billion
pounds extra in council tax over the
next few years that's always hitting the
same people
labor believe that those with the
broadest shoulders who get their incomes
through stocks and shares and buy to let
property portfolios and the online
giants should be paying a fairer share
of tax to ease the burden on ordinary
working people ahead of cop 26 the uh
chancellor said he is a green chancellor
i think the only way to be a responsible
chancellor today is to be a green
chancellor but look at what the
chancellor announced yesterday a cut in
air passenger duty for domestic flights
making it cheaper to fly from london to
manchester or from uh newcastle to
manchester those are the wrong decisions
and i find it astonishing the week
before cop 26 when we're supposed to be
showing global leadership that the
chancellor yesterday did nothing of the
sort and indeed with um tackling net
zero the chancellor is just putting the
burden on people
rather than taking a leadership role
himself so
there's huge opportunities with um with
electric vehicles with the hydrogen
industry with carbon capture and storage
to create good quality high skilled high
paid jobs in coastal communities in
former industrial communities and there
was almost no reference to that
yesterday in the chancellor's speech a
real missed opportunity to create those
high paid high skilled jobs of the
future in this country just before i let
you go tell me how the conversation went
yesterday morning hi rachel
um it's kia here
so um so at quarter to 12 45 minutes
before the budget began i was told
that kia had tested positive for covid
um i mean what a nightmare so i have 45
minutes basically to prepare my speech
now my background is as an economist and
i think i put that to good use
yesterday in getting on top of the
issues and and then sitting during the
budget listening to the chancellor's
speech and trying to respond to that uh
as quickly and as best as um i could so
i hope we did a good job yesterday
well it's the sort of thing you wake up
in a cold sweat in the middle of the
night it's
but luckily i didn't have uh
all that time to worry about it just had
to get on and do my job and how is he
he's good i spoke to him yesterday uh
after obviously frustrated um but as he
said to me earlier in the week i think
i'm the only person who hasn't got
covered
and
be careful what you say yeah good to
talk to you well done thank you thank